the trouble was water and power at
California Heights is a feature-length
documentary about the politics of water
in California California officials are
putting mandatory restrictions on water
use in place water has become gold in
the midst of this drought agriculture
has recorded record crops so the
question becomes how they manage to do
them the California Aqueduct was set up
by Governor Pat Brown Jerry Brown's
father a river 700 miles long the
largest project ever undertaken by an
American state we have an artificial
river running through its desert States
[Music]
there are so many different layers in
this world of waters there are a lot of
manipulations behind the scenes that
we've known nothing about and our film
focuses on a series of meetings where a
water bank ended up getting out of the
hands of the state of California and
into the hands of some private
individual
there was nothing illegal about what
they did because most of what they do is
legal because they write the rules
it's an expose of green basically so I
hope people will kind of say wow this is
happening and we need to band together
and try to fix it
[Music]